hola cómo estás bienvenido a mi
presentación sobre desigualdades
cuadráticas y bueno en una primera
instancia quiero verlo de una manera
visual para que entiendas bien a qué me
refiero con una desigualdad cuadrática
así que empecemos pero antes de ver
desigualdades vamos a trabajar con una
función cuadrática y de aquí vamos a
partir así que imagínate que yo me tomo
la función
efe x f x igual a x cuadrada más x menos
6 bueno tú me puedes decir que esto
representa una parábola que abre hacia
arriba pero cuáles son sus raíces ahora
recuerda que si nosotros queremos sacar
las raíces de esta función cuadrática
que tengo aquí lo que hay que hacer es
igualar esta función a 0 las raíces de
una función es igualdad esa función a
cero o dicho de otra manera recuerda que
una raíz es donde cortamos al eje de las
x donde cortamos el eje de las x que
estamos diciendo que la función vale 0
entonces vamos a sacar las raíces
pongámoslo así x cuadrado más x menos 6
menos 6 esto quiero que sea igual a 0 y
esta expresión aquí la podemos
actualizar necesito dos números cuya
multiplicación cuyo producto sea menos 6
y cuya suma o en dado caso en este caso
más bien cuya resta sea 1 y bueno tú me
puedes decir que esos dos números es a 3
y 2 y 2 negativo 3 y menos 2 por lo
tanto puede escribir esto como x + 3 x 3
que a su vez multiplica a x menos 2 y
esto es exactamente igual a 0 y esto es
exactamente igual a 0 lo que quiere
decir que este 0 o en su dado caso el
otro 0 o este 0 si el primero 0
me quedaría que x + 3 es igual a cero o
dicho otra manera x es igual a menos 3 y
esta es la primera rueda y ahora si esto
es 0 me quedaría que x menos 2 es igual
a cero o dicho otra manera x es igual a
y estas dos son las raíces
las raíces y 6 de este polinomio y de
esta función que tengo aquí ahora qué te
parece si lo visualizamos de una manera
gráfica vamos a hacer la gráfica de esta
función que tengo aquí así que para eso
voy a poner aquí a medidas x ok
este es mi eje x y por aquí también
perfecto este va a ser mi hija le íbamos
a poner que este es mi eje x este eje
perdón y este es mi eje x y aquí tengo a
al 212 por aquí tengo el 2 y por aquí
tengo al menos 3 1 2 3
-3 ok y si te das cuenta
esta es una parábola que abre hacia
arriba y cruza justo aquí y justo aquí
así que vamos a dibujarla me voy a tomar
a una parábola que pasó por aquí que
pase por aquí y que abra hacia arriba
así que a van por aquí y va por aquí mi
parábola va por aquí llega hasta este
punto después si nosotros hacemos x
igual a cero aquí tenemos el valor de
menos 6 menos 6 vamos a llegar hasta
este punto aquí pero vamos a llegar
hasta este punto me voy por aquí me voy
por aquí digamos este punto y de aquí
empezamos a subir empezamos a subir
pasamos por la otra raíz ok y después
subimos y subimos y subimos perfecto ya
tengo mi palabra que hable hacia arriba
ahora quiero que te des cuenta que este
es el punto menos 30 menos 30 aunque
vamos a ocupar y este es el punto 20
ahora pensemos un poco en desigualdades
y estuvo bien de pensar en funciones qué
te parece si ahora te pongo la siguiente
desigualdad
yo quiero saber donde la función fx es
mayor que es 0 y bueno fx es más grande
que 0 esto es exactamente lo mismo que
pensar que x cuadrada más x menos 6
menos 6 esto sea mayor que 0 que crees
tenemos una desigualdad de segundo grado
que es curso lo que queremos ver en este
vídeo tengo la desigualdad es cuadrada
más x menos 6 esto es mayor que 0 y yo
quiero saber dónde es esto siento ahora
esto es lo mismo que pensar que fx sea
mayor que 0 y si te das cuenta aquí aquí
tengo a fx más grande que 0 justo por
aquí
ok todos estos valores son los valores
donde y 10 más grande que 0 y por acá
también todos estos valores son los
valores donde ya es más grande que 0 y
son los únicos porque a partir de aquí
esto se hace negativo y da un valor
positivo por lo tanto mis valores
solución de esta desigualdad son estos
de aquí pero como luego tienen términos
de x me voy a fijar en las x a partir de
aquí qué
hagan que esta desigualdad se cumpla y
esto es las primas x que tengo aquí son
todas estas x de aquí ok y también todas
estas x de aquí hacen que esta
desigualdad se cumpla es decir todas las
x que son más grandes que dos o más
pequeñas que menos tres las x que
solucionan a esta desigualdad de aquí
son las x que son más pequeñas que menos
3 o en su dado caso las x que son más
grandes que 2 que son justo estas de
aquí este de aquí y esta de aquí cuando
y es positivo es cuando x vale algo más
pequeño que menos 3 o más grande que 2 y
no puede valer menos tres nidos porque
en esos puntos nuestra función se hace
cero entonces si queremos la solución de
esta desigualdad que tengo aquí que por
cierto es una desigualdad cuadrática
visto de una manera visual es las equis
que son más pequeñas que menos 3 las x
que son más grandes que dos y de hecho
tú puedes ser el intento con cualquier x
que a ti se te ocurra que esté aquí
por ejemplo puedes probar con -4 meterle
aquí y ver que realmente funciona esta
desigualdad o en soldado caso por tomar
una equis más grande que dos supongamos
x 3 meterla en esta función en esta
desigualdad de que tengo aquí y ver que
realmente se cumple pero bueno este es
un caso que me gusta mucho porque
estamos viendo una manera visual ahora
qué te parece si seguimos trabajando con
desigualdades de segundo grado voy a
pensar en la siguiente desigualdad y me
voy a tomar menos x cuadrada menos 3 x
más 28 más 28 y esto quiero que sea más
grande o igual que 0 ahora lo primero
que quiero que veas aquí y lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta es que
tenemos una desigualdad cuadrática por
lo tanto vamos bien estamos en el vídeo
de desigualdades cuadráticas ahora lo
segundo que quiero que veas que tenemos
una desigualdad donde el término que
está al lado de la x cuadrada es
negativo yo te recomiendo y más bien es
mi punto de vista que siempre lo
conviertas en positivo para que sea más
fácil factory
o resolver esta desigualdad cuadrática
por el método que tú quieras así que
para volverlo positivo voy a multiplicar
toda esta desigualdad por menos 1 ahora
quiero que recuerde algo muy importante
cuando yo multiplico o divido por un
número negativo la desigualdad se voltea
es decir que ahorita que vamos a
multiplicar todo por menos 1 esta
desigualdad va a cambiar de signo y en
lugar de ser mayor que va a ser menor
que así que vamos a hacerlo me va a
quedar a menos x menos me va a dar más
más ex cuadrada
menos x menos nada más no va a quedar
más 3 x menos por más me dan menos menos
28 estamos cambiando todo el signo y
aquí tengo esta desigualdad que va a
voltear se va a pasar ahora menor que y
esto es menor que es 0 ok
ya que tenemos esta desigualdad con el
término de x cuadrada positivo que te
parece si factor izamos el lado
izquierdo vamos a aprovechar el lado
izquierdo intentando buscar las raíces
de la misma manera que lo hicimos hace
rato en el problema de hace rato y
quiero dos números cuyo producto sea 28
ok menos 28 y cuya suma o resta sea 32
números y un 7 por 4 28 ok aquí están 7
positivo y 4 negativo me dan estos dos
valores que tengo aquí es decir que esto
de aquí en la parte izquierda de esta
desigualdad la podemos ver de la
siguiente manera esto es exactamente lo
mismo
que fue paréntesis esto es exactamente
lo mismo también no me gustó que x + 7
ok que a su vez multiplica a x menos 4
y esto de aquí representa esta parte que
tenemos aquí pero no olvidemos la
desigualdad esto quiero que sea más
pequeño que 0 más pequeño que es 0 de
lujo ahora ya que tenemos en esta parte
izquierda factor izada me da la noción
de que ya podemos definir la función
para encontrar sus raíces justo como lo
vimos hace ratito
es decir que si yo te bautizo a fx voy a
decir que fx es igual y bueno me puedo
tomar esta expresión de aquí o esté aquí
pero creo que prefiero tomarme la iata
actualizada
fx es igual a x + 7 que multiplica a su
vez a x menos 4 ok entonces de una
manera muy sencilla podemos concluir que
sus raíces raíces sería igualar esto a 0
y cuando nosotros igualamos esto 0
tenemos qué x es igual a menos 7 en su
dado caso x es igual
estas son las raíces de esta función
fx pero nosotros realmente queremos
resolver esta desigualdad ahora te voy a
dar un gran consejo la solución siempre
va a estar entre estos dos valores o en
su dado caso va a estar afuera de estos
dos valores es decir las x que son más
pequeñas que menos 7 y más grandes que 4
o en su dado caso las x que están entre
estos dos valores y siempre la solución
es esa un gran consejo o una forma fácil
de ver este tipo de problemas es simple
visualizar que la solución está entre
estos dos valores o está afuera de estos
dos menores y para eso qué te parece si
probamos que 'no un valor que esté entre
estos dos así que a mí se me ocurre
tomar este color y vamos a decir que
vamos a probar probar
con x igual a 0 si x vale 0 cuánto vale
fx
bueno pues efe de 0 efe de 0 es decir
cuando x vale 0
es lo mismo que 07 que multiplica a cero
menos 4 y esto es lo mismo que 7 que
multiplica a menos 4 ok lo voy a poner
en paréntesis y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que menos 28 y menos 28 es un
número menor que cero por lo tanto ya
encontramos la solución de este problema
la solución de esta desigualdad que
tengo aquí son las x que están entre
menos 7 y 4 y vamos a ponerlo así menos
7 es menor que x que es menor que 4 ok
esto es un conjunto solución de esta
desigualdad que tengo aquí arriba y cómo
se son bueno porque probamos un número
que estaba entre estos dos valores y
obtuvimos un valor válido para esta
desigualdad ahora tú puedes probar tal
vez otro valor que no sea cero que esté
fuera de estos dos valores es decir
supongamos que tomamos uno más alejado
estos dos no se me ocurre tomar 5
vamos a probar probar para x igual a 5
bueno pues efe de 5 en este caso esto no
es un 5 en este caso es igual a 5 7 12
12 por cinco menos cuatro es 11 lo cual
es 12 y 12 no está en esta desigualdad
así que en definitiva podemos concluir
que este es el conjunto solución de esta
desigualdad ya probamos sobre el medio y
si está uno fuera y no está y por lo
tanto ya podemos decir que esta
desigualdad tiene como conjunto solución
este equipo ahora lo padre de todo esto
es que si tú quieres incluir las raíces
entonces tendremos una desigualdad mayor
o igual mayor o igual mayor o igual
menor o igual menor o igual y en este
caso si incluimos las raíces cuando
nosotros incluimos las raíces es cuando
nosotros tenemos una desigualdad inicial
con mayor o igual o el sudado caso menor
igual y bueno si nosotros queremos ver
esto de una manera visual
vamos a acabar el vídeo viendo esto de
una manera visual a una visita de kim y
vamos a hacer es decir que este es mi
eje y este es mi eje x ok vamos a poner
este es mi eje x este es mi eje
jeff ok y bueno mis raíces son menos 74
así que supongamos que aquí está el 4 ok
y por aquí va a estar el -7 ok ahora
fíjate que esta de aquí esta de aquí es
estar aquí es una palabra que abre hacia
arriba así que vamos a dibujar una
parábola también que abre hacia arriba y
se manda este color vamos a dibujar una
parábola que abre hacia arriba más o
menos así va a llegar a este punto ok y
después va a subir
más o menos así y yo estoy preguntando
es cuando de x es menor o igual que 0
estoy fijándome en esta expresión que
tengo aquí quiero que fx sea menor o
igual que 0 y bueno si te das cuenta es
igual a 0 en estos dos puntos y fx es
menor que cero y vamos a ponerlo con
este color en estos dos puntos es igual
a cero y es menor que cero justo en
medio de estos dos valores en medio de
estos dos valores es cuando se hace esta
función menor o igual que cero que es lo
que quería mi desigualdad y bueno el
caso contrario si nosotros quisiéramos
ver donde es mayor o igual que cero es
justo como te decía sería en los
extremos afuera de este intervalo es
decir me tomaría estos valores de aquí y
estos valores de aquí pero bueno no es
este caso espero no haber confundido y
entonces podemos concluir que la
solución de esta desigualdad que tengo
aquí es menos 7 menor o igual que x
menor o igual que 4 y lo encontramos
obteniendo las raíces y probando con un
número que esté entre ellos dos
es un gran consejo que te puedo dar para
encontrar de una manera muy sencilla y
muy rápida la solución de este tipo de
desigualdades